merci merci été moins nombreux à le
mériter les acteurs nommés notamment ce
soir et bien d'autres encore je voudrais
remercier tous les réalisateurs avec
lesquels j'ai bossé depuis 30 ans à peu
près maintenant parce qu'ils m'ont
permis d'obtenir et d'avoir cette chose
nécessaire pour un acteur à savoir un
parcours et c'est ce parcours qui me
permet d'être avec vous ce soir et de
recevoir cette récompense
c'est je fais un métier qui m'a permis
de me permet de vivre une expérience
exceptionnelle extraordinaire captivante
et donc je voudrais dire à tous et
metteur en scène que ils ont toute ma
gratitude tout mon respect je voudrais
aussi transmettre mon respect à arnaud
magique despléchin qui transforme le
moyen en bon le bon un très bon le très
bon en excellence merci merci pour cette
invitation merci pour ton regard
merci pour ce rôle
meilleur acteur certainement pas mais en
rôle peut-être mais franchement et
j'aimerais aussi remercier les
partenaires sahara mais à antoine et
tous les acteurs se sont improvisés
acteurs et des habitants de roubaix qui
sont finalement l'âme et la lumière du
film
je voudrais dire aussi à tous ceux qui
ont le sentiment dans la vie parfois de
partir d'un peu trop loin que ce qui est
important c'est pas ce n'est pas de
courir vite dans l'espoir de rattraper
ceux qui sont devant mais de courir plus
longtemps et pour terminer je voudrais
dédier ce césar ham et de héros fatima
et gilali 100 m
mes parents ils ont fait ce que je suis
je leur dois tout et soyez en sûr s'il
était là il vous remercierai un par un
jeu
c'est pour eux merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]